offensive rebound Collins McCullen pulls
it back and a beautiful shot by CJ
McCollum four-point blazer lead three
minutes gone by in the fourth as Martin
Luther sat in traffic collins ahead of
the pack looking for some pellet but
colon comes to the rescue and finishes
off the window sitting has had to take
over on the offensive end he's been
aggressive assertive excellent use of
the left hand he's been quiet since a
couple of quick buckets to start the
third quarter he still has 20 points for
the game McCollum gets past keep
shooting McCollum has probably always
been a bit undersized so getting
separation using your handle using your
touch he is moving away from the rim
that is not easy
TAC double-teamed and turns it over
excellent defensive possession of a
half-court at Cantor is really hurting
Dave what column pulls up and scores
he ties it at 104 now stops it with a
shot clock at seven
it gets it back McCullum's three
[Applause]
blazars tonight he's six 390 pounds and
he's a big shot after big shot feel the
love CJ that's a beautiful shot shot
clock is off limit aches it himself and
blue the way out to Aminu here's
McCollum driving now the clock you end
up with a turnover
Lillard misses a little finger roll
great job by Aminu to keep control and
CJ delivers yet again all seven Miller
try to shake Harris runs into yo get
shot clock down to 3 here's McCollum
another teardrop not that time got his
own this
shot clock down to six McCullum comes
and gets it with a timer for farting on
him McCullum drives two on the shot
clock
each chance he gets being physical with
him 47 minutes played for cancer here's
McCollum trying to shake Gil Kitts
buries the jumper CJ McCollum a 36
you're getting the switch so here comes
the screen by Kanter you've got to make
the switch because Kanter does a good
job holding up that guy and go Ahead's
happening but that's a sloppy pass
McCollum step back over Barton it's gone
again CJ McCollum can't miss they double
Lillard to force him to give it up
here's McCollum again
[Applause]
mismatched on the box as number to show
you McCallum first this is off of the
defensive play that was made by Portland
on the other end so Cantor yet again
another screen to hold Barton up and CJ
with an exhausted mismatch on the box as
were to show you McCollum first this is
off of the defensive play the column
driving over to Nuggets off the heels
got it back to hood he'll try a 3
players by 2
but win on the road CJ over two
defenders offensive rebounds his own
miss how about the up fake and poised to
stay in three by mr. hood who also had
three blocks the last game look at him
this isn't somebody who's dunking in the
corner this is I'm out here at three on
Roland slide by the defender you don't
show discipline I put it down the
acquisitions by Niall O'Shea and Terry
Stotts